[Applause]
yes that is the title track of mary
morris's critically acclaimed 2019 album
girl
an album that also contained the
two-time platinum hit the bones
which spent an incredible 19 weeks at
number one
on billboard's hot country songs chart
where it became the longest leading us
number one by a solo female artist but
marin isn't solo at home she and husband
ryan heard
of the busy new parents to a
five-month-old son
named hayes if you were to write a song
right now what would the title be about
your life
tired i don't know
you get to watch your husband become a
dad like how cool is that
yeah it's like weird but it is kind of
the hottest thing it's just to see
isn't it you're a guy like holding a
baby and taking care of it
it's just like it's like completely like
natured response to be like
wow you're really hot ah i love that you
know one of the great things about kids
is the fashion i
love that you posted the jean jacket
that was given to you by miranda
how cute is that is it one of the best
gifts you've gotten
oh yeah i mean it's i love that it's
personalized it's
blinged out i mean he looks like a
little baby elton john
in it my husband's like oh yeah what son
wouldn't want to match with his mother
i'm so excited to hopefully you know
it'll still fit him when
we can go out he's getting so big he's
i feel like he's going to be tall like
his dad he doesn't fit in his
age size of clothing anymore he's like
his
eyes up but no he's adorable and he's so
smiley and
sweet right now and hopefully it stays
like that you know i just want to say
thank you for actually talking about
your experience
it's the fact that you you were in labor
for 30 hours
you had a c-section you you know you
threw this pandemic where people
couldn't visit you at the hospital then
you talked about
postpartum which i can totally relate to
what have you learned about yourself
through this
i've gone through so many waves like i'm
sure as you know
after you have a baby there's just so
many hormonal
things that are trying to level back out
and it takes
time and i think just what i can
physically and emotionally withstand i
feel like my threshold is way higher
than i
once thought and i think like i've grown
more
patient over the month because i've had
to
you know not only with a baby but just
with life kind of
shutting down i've had to really take a
pause and
figure out you know things i love
outside of music
and touring and so i feel like it's just
out of
necessity taught me to be more patient
and not rush to the next thing
but marin is still keeping busy earlier
this summer she released
reimagined the acoustic songs are a
fresh take on some of her biggest hits
[Music]
and despite marin's intentions to slow
down she tells us
she's already hard at work on the next
album you talked about the fact that
you're creating music right now and i
think you tweeted
it's sad as af i'm so happy is that just
all about
mom life well i mean i just even
if i'm like the happiest person in the
world i write the saddest songs i don't
know why it's not like
synonymous with my mood that day it just
happens to come out really sad if i'm
happy and then
i'll be sad and want to write a happy
song so
but that will be a good mix i hope of
both on that on the new record
[Music]